data has the power to turn the world
upside down the business analyst who
speaks to data can leverage the highest
potential to bring exponential growth to
the organization by tapping the critical
unexplored business information major
tech giants like amazon walmart meta and
many more are eagerly looking out for
certified business analysis
professionals and are also ready to
compensate with attractive salary
packages ranging from seventy thousand
dollars to one hundred and twenty
thousand dollars per annum
this potential requirement opens up
lucrative career opportunities in the
world of data analysis
if you are the one who likes wrapping
your arms around data questioning it and
solving the puzzles around it then scale
up's complete business analysis
professional certification is just what
you need to upskill and get ahead
this course is curated in collaboration
with leading data analysis giants and
real-time industry experts to make sure
the program covers the critical skills
techniques and hands-on experience with
the powerful business intelligence tools
to make sure the learners are industry
ready the best part is all of this is
for free of cost
yes you heard me right and you can start
your business analysis journey for free
of cost
the course is 8 hours long and all the
modules in it are self-paced video
lessons
with 90 days of access to the entire
course
this allows you to learn at your own
pace anytime anywhere after completing
this course you will receive a course
completion certificate from scala this
certificate can be shared within your
professional circle the course comprises
cutting-edge technicalities in and
around business analysis using the
leading business intelligence tools and
techniques
first we will learn a brief overview of
business analysis planning a solution
and monitoring the changes
then we will look into business process
management perspective followed by that
we will deal with the requirement life
cycle management next we will learn
about the requirement analysis and
design definition later we will focus on
business architecture perspective for
the same
advancing we will deal with elicitation
and collaboration down the line we will
learn about strategy analysis finally we
will find out the certification program
by understanding the business
intelligence perspective
by the end of this course you will
become an expert business analysis
professional so now you might be
thinking who is eligible to take this
course well there are no prerequisites
to enroll to this course each of you who
has the zeal of learning market and
business data analysis can take up this
course irrespective of your experience
so what are you waiting for head
straight to our scale up page and enrich
your business analysis skills by
enrolling in our free course today get
closer to your dreams and what can get
better than a free certificate to
strengthen your profile certifications
bring you one step closer to backing the
opportunity and becoming a business
analysis expert today
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here